so hi everyone i'm ignacio or natural i
am based in london and i work with many
game developers across the western
europe region so many you in fact i see
a lot of familiar faces so thanks for
coming after the break
thanks for being here and today we're
going to talk about all games which in
some cases and some instances might be
your first success and we are going to
understand whether these they aged
better or worse and the goal of this
session is basically well that was that
was a stronger introduction so the goal
of this session is essentially to
understand what are the different
strategies so if these games are
becoming a burden or a technology debt
or if these are actually the new
opportunity that you can actually follow
and to do that i will have on stage two
fantastic speakers so eric CEO of do
dreams and as well a net vp of business
and marketing from dirty bit so i wanted
to start with a very easy example
because we were thinking about all games
then i thought all right let's look at
all games and how how they look like
today so we have two games here both of
them by the rational developer games
inside i don't know if you're familiar
with them but tribe's was published at
six years ago in 2012 and we have as
well transfer empire published in 2014
four years ago and there's a big
difference among these developers i
don't know if you maybe you can guess if
you are obviously working for games in
sides you would know okay so I'm just
gonna so essentially what happens with
these games is that one of these games
is actually a priority today still it
represents a big part of the revenues so
when were I was I was looking at old
games we basically identified that some
of these old games they became an
evergreen title and even though it's
been a long time since they were
published they still represent a very
important source of revenues for the
developer and as well these translates
into having these resources into the
game and transfer Empire would be part
of that back catalogue so the first
things you can see there is this one if
we look at another two examples here
both of them in these case our top
priorities for both developers however
if you look at the right side
we might think that this game is it
looks classier or at least slightly
older and in fact old school by room
skated runescape old school by Jagex was
published in PC for the first time 17
years ago so it makes sense while
responding was the legends was published
five years ago only however if you are a
fan of runescape old-school you would
know that the game hasn't been laund
yet in mobile is in fact mounting in two
weeks the second of November so when we
are talking about like why isn't a game
old or how is an old game how do we
define these is it like by the launch
date by when the game was released in PC
in the case of runescape or maybe it's
just one year five years or two years so
this is two things that we need to have
in mind and then we were trying to
figure out how these games are
performing nowadays in play and we had
to take two assumptions which are very
peak assumptions in the first case was
when the game was published and so we
are going to look at games that they
were published four years or older and
then also if this game represents a top
priority for the company if the games is
driving most of the revenues then in
this case we would consider an outlier
so we're making the assumption of like
less than fifty percent of the overall
portfolio of the developer so if we look
at these and we take this into into
account and we look at the top games by
revenue and downloads in the Play Store
we will see that in fact all games are
very much alive and kicking and what it
means is that so first of all all games
these games with this four years old and
as well less than 50% they represent 17%
of those top revenue games in the Play
Store and as well they receive new users
every day 17.5% of the downloads in the
past six months were gone to these
titles from an engagement perspective
it's something similar we see that these
old games they seem to have very engaged
communities and and fans that they keep
playing and on average 59% of daily
active users more than the newer games
on the other hand the design of the
games is seems to be short shorter terms
so shorter times and we see that on
average
they spend less time for daily active
users or 29% less also we take into
account monetization with in-app
purchases in particular we will see that
all games they tend to monetize a
slightly less better and we see - 18% in
our Tao and last but not least as
everything all in this life it tends to
have some issues and we see that also
from a vitals perspective they have on
average 50% more crash rates and 20%
more ANR's so in a natural these games
these four-year-old games they have a
lot of new fresh installs new users
coming every day they still make a lot
of a significant revenue although might
be slightly lower and they have some
issues in terms of in terms of for
example vitals and crash rates and ANR's
and the question here is is these a
burden do we consider these games as
technology debt or do we consider an
opportunity and so there is two very
clear ways but there is three routes so
there's three common ways that
developers are following so if you go to
the the the very much I can see that
this is a burden the ultimate case is to
unpublish the game and this is the case
that we will hear from dirty bit later
on if you go on the other hand I can see
that this is my biggest opportunity then
why not I put more resources into this
game and try to revamp it and become
again one of my top drive drivers of
revenue and this is the case from do
dreams later on and what when we ask
developers we found out that majority of
you they you go into what we call the
the back catalogue mode or longtail or
start of school and so we ask how do a
gains end up in this mode so there's a
couple of common factors so many times
we see that in LiveOps new content
updates they don't have the same effect
as well they are I campaigns they try to
stabilize LTV is very similar to CP is
other factors could be also affecting
for example cannibalization between your
own games you launch a new game and you
see a lot of users from the previous one
going to this title and as well external
factors such as competitors or new
generals that are appearing
and does this mean that the game is dead
well actually no and that's that's for
sure like we we still have very engaged
communities and as games insights was
sharing with us brand perception is very
important and keeping alive this game is
critical for them but also generally
they are very profitable so if we look
at games instance as well we see that
all games or longtail games generate 14%
of the total revenues and on average
they have 50% more profits than the
newer ones so what are the key
challenges so I put like three key
challenges there might be more but the
main ones would be first a spaghetti
code so some problems with the as the
case we've seen that they have some
issues with technical problems like
ANR's and crash rates also as well
monetization is hard to keep up with the
CPMs updating the mediation platforms as
well sometimes you might see that your
game is using agencies that they do not
exist or networks that they are not
anymore and last team every developer is
looking forward to work in the next
title in the next big head and
convincing then motivating the users or
the developers to actually work in this
game might be hard so just to finalize
this some very few recommendations from
also another developer here today with
us so a belief so we have to tackle
these precise challenges we can think
about like the ways to optimize target
SDK how we can keep updated the game
they of the versions of the engine in a
efficient way may be outsourcing another
way also of thinking is like how do we
keep an efficient monetization by
updating automatically the CPM or write
for example automatize in the customer
support whenever the players are using
in-app purchases another a very
interesting example automatize in live
ops so for example the Halloween sales
or the Halloween live ops that you're
running this year might be the same as
the last year but users they might not
know the players might not know that
this is exactly the same so and that
keeps like the game fresh and alive and
last but not least we've seen today a
number of examples of how can you
improve your conversion via store
listings for
sample country targeting we have it now
and these will help you to drive and
continue driving those users to your
game and with this I would like to
invite a stage and a distillery who is
going to talk about a different way
which is in this case is to actually go
and publishing hi everyone thank you for
coming it's my first time at playtime
event and my first time in Berlin
actually so I joined the games industry
and the Norwegian studio called dirty
bit three years ago and I work in the
management team together with the
founders so working for a small company
means that I work with both management
business development marketing adopts
dirty bit was founded in 2011 and I've
been part of the company since we were 8
and 2 a team of 18 today we're based in
Bergen on the west coast of Norway
anybody who has been in Bergen here Oh
quite a few
cool so we're owned by the founders and
us employees we make and publish
free-to-play games and we monetize on in
a purchase and ads two of the founders
grew up together in Bergen and they had
many fond memories of beating each other
in Mario Kart so when they started
making games they could find a lot of
multiplayer games with a world
turn-based so they took on the challenge
of making a real-time multiplayer game
and remember this was in 2011 so this
was quite unique at the time this is how
it looked have anyone played it nice so
the game started spreading in schools in
the US and it went viral in social media
it trended trended on Twitter and it
reached the top charts overall in the US
and many other countries not bad for a
very small and young team from Norway so
in April this year we had three games
live all in the front row and series as
you can see fun run that was launched in
2012 the next one in 2014
so even if we had all these games live
they all games were still getting
downloads and had significant user bases
but most of our efforts were into the
what I call the new game which is
launched in 2016 so what we saw is that
even if it brings most of our revenue
it only gets about half of our downloads
so fast we're waiting a few months this
is how it looks today so now we can see
that the new game news game has more
than 99 percent for downloads and it's
also bringing in most of the revenue so
what happened last year our current
strategy as it had been for several
years was to grow with the user base and
we actually reached hundred million
downloads all organic no paid you a
that's pretty cool right so a sorry
network in the industry guru and many of
you started sharing numbers with us and
we got a little help from a penny
premium we realized that we had a lot to
improve when it comes to monetization we
hired a full-time analyst and that
helped us transitioning from basing most
of our decisions on gut feeling to
really diving into the numbers we
started doing some UA and it became more
clear that we need a new strategy to
increase our revenue so that's what
we've been doing this year is focusing
on the numbers analyzing everything and
our analysts introduced this term of mmm
making more money maybe you do that the
same as well we have been very careful
it's scared of harming the user
experience so we have been trying to
enhance our monetization and it's been
well received and everybody is happy the
analyst is happy and we're happy we've
been working more focused with ASO and I
brought this example here when we first
launched 103 Arena we didn't even call
it 403 we call it fun run arena because
our gut feeling said that that was the
right thing to do so this was the icon
also based on gut feeling a year after
launch we did the experiment
in Google Play just adding the number
three and as you can see the results it
became clear to us that we should update
the both the title and the icon so
thunderin 3 was clearly our star but
what's the challenge but the
monetization when we compared it to the
older titles two to four times better
ARP Dow retention was clearly a lot
better technology we built the newest
game in unity which made it easier for
us to maintain this is the game where we
had the dedicated team and want to
deliver the best gameplay and best user
experience and I know that nacho and
Toby if you've seen their talks before
you might have heard them talking about
we live in a post launch world and we
agree and we plan to do live ups for
this game to improve it make it even
better for a long time so the challenges
as you can see from some numbers from
ebony showing our most important keyword
the user is searching for our game found
the old titles and they were a bit
confused it seemed to what to download
we even got a big featuring for fun run
- and thank you very much we appreciated
that but it didn't help us grow for
round three we tried to UM optimize I
don't know if you've tried it it can be
pretty tricky when you have millions of
downloads within a lot of historical
data when we launched Finneran 1 & 2 we
had organic growth we had the games went
viral hit the top charts we couldn't do
that the same and we were competing not
only with all the games in the market
but also ourselves so here you can see
what happened when we started testing
removing thunder and one from Turkey
where we had a significant user base
people started downloading fun and - not
fun 1 3 so when we removed Fun Run 2
from the market finally people were
starting to download thunder and 3 as
well and it started to grow so we
decided to unpublish like not you talked
about
we saw from the test that we expected
the new game to absorb 90% of the
downloads Thunder in 3 was the game we
wanted our users to download and the
monetization was better we wanted to be
open with our community and inform them
that we were going to focus on four and
three going forward and we expected a
backlash we were right one or three
absorbed most of the downloads and it's
been growing since so we increased our
user base in front and three overall we
lost users but that was because we
remove it removed older games we managed
to increase our revenue this is from
April to August and August in September
has been looking pretty nice as well we
have been able to free up resources to
do the great live ups we want to do for
from entry so our key learnings is we
tested in a market where we had a
significant user base we not knew what
numbers to look for and we made
decisions based on the key metrics and
we were prepared to let the first game
go even if there is a lot of nostalgia
there as well we plan for the best and
the worst case scenario and we had some
had a plan B do not underestimate the
impact on your community and I brought
this example today because if we still
have a very active fun run to community
they even made a petition to make us
bring the game back every time we post
something in social media like I did
today from here first reply is please
remember thunder and tirion they made a
very touching video with music so this
happens every time so even though some
of our players rated 403 with one star
because they want us to bring the back
we have a very active community playing
thunder entry creating content and
helping us grow organically so for us
the right decision was to divest so I
have the honor of inviting my good
friend Eric to the stage to talk about
their approach which
was a bit different thank you thank you
very much hello everyone my name is Eric
and I'm the CEO with two dreams it's
really exciting to be here in Berlin at
playtime and honored to share the stage
with my dear friends not shown on it I
will present today or talk about our
portfolio strategy I will present what
kind of choices we made explain what was
the logic behind those choices and then
present what kind of impact it had on
our business a to dreams we make games
where players do stuff that dreams are
made of
so we are do dreams and we are the
makers of this drive ahead portfolio of
games this key art is for our game drive
ahead drive ahead is a gladiator car
fight game so what that means is you get
points by hitting your friend in the
head with a car and thank you for that
reaction because that's what 100 million
people all around all around the world
think also when they decided to download
the game so it's it's a really fun and
simple premise and in our vision drive
ahead games are the best way to play
share and watch fun gaming content so we
have a very large and active a community
built around video for the game and
thanks to this community we're getting
100,000 new downloads every single day
and this is what the game originally
looked like so it was developed for a
sauna party by one of our employees so
he was having some beers with his
friends and and they came up with this
idea that hey what would it look like if
a tank would be battling a lorry truck
and let's put a garbage truck there and
against the go-kart or something like
that so even today the game looks pretty
the same and the core gameplay of course
we brought a lot of other stuff to it so
that the first game went live in 2015
and in 2016 we decided that let's have a
portfolio strategy business logic there
is that we'll do a cross-promotion we're
gonna get the higher number of daily
active users and then we're gonna make
more money and and then also we had
realized that when we made the first
game maybe we weren't so experienced or
we made some mistake so you know instead
of going through the trouble of updating
in the first game let's just fix
everything that we did wrong at one go
and we were quite experimental with it
so we decided that instead of just
making the first this is the second game
let's experiment a little bit so we had
an idea for drive ahead sports so you
can play soccer and other sports with
cars so we made it first an event in the
original game and when we told fans that
summer is over soccer is going away
then they started begging us to bring it
back and we said well you can play it
but it's going to be it's a standalone
game and in 2016 actually actually it
had significant contribution to the
studio revenue in 2017 we realized that
this portfolio approach isn't working
perfectly for us so drive head sports
turned out to be even more skilled game
than the original game so it's it's
reaching a more niche audience we were
able to be better in the free-to-play
design of the game so for example our
Tao is 2.5 times higher but that doesn't
really help when you're reaching only
20% of the players from the original
title and the really ugly thing we did
in 2017 was that we tried to fix
everything once again at the one go so
we made a major change where you know
change the UI UX added a saga map and
tons of other thing and everybody hated
it so we lost half of the players and
revenue and returns and was was almost
destroyed and nearly killed the game and
then we also went all-in with AR so we
made a game called drive ahead mini golf
so if we have car gladiators this is
what they do in their free time and
turned out that we were there a little
bit too early and we're doing fancy
motion controls with the device people
were playing mini golf like this and it
didn't work out either so we discovered
that you know this is a bit risky as an
approach so the decision was that let's
focus on the original title is getting
that 100,000 new players a day good
things are that there's high engagement
and virality through the community we
realized that you know we're only we've
only scratched the service surface with
monetization potential there so that's a
picture of our team there with our head
of studio talking to them and this is
the group that was given the task to to
revamp the game we our approach was the
following we realized that it's too much
risk changing things in the game like
making two big changes but we had
started doing live ops which is a really
great place to change the rules of the
game and and we see what works there and
then bring it into the actual game and
so what happened next was that we
started doing these iterations so first
we redid the first time user experience
to teach the players how to watch ads as
a daily habit and show the value of
growing your collection in the game and
then in the second is innocent in
iteration was our live ops events where
we had the play gave the players the
feature that they could build a deck of
cards deck of cars that they use in a
boss fight
so both experiments increased add
engagement rate by 50% and
our engagement is one of our key KPIs
so the lessons we learned here was that
when you launch a new game in a
portfolio you have to very clearly
define what is the positioning of that
product and why should it exist as a
standalone game and it's what has worked
really well for us is validating new
features content even new games with the
community we found that when we openly
say that this is the good stuff of our
game and this is what we're trying to
fix it actually attracts new talent and
and ignites the passion of the team so
we've had really senior people join the
studio because they say that the
problems you guys have our fun problems
to solve so let's fix monetization when
you have a big community and you might
wonder what happened to drive ahead
sports so we still have it live and we
empowered a fresh young talented team to
take over ship ownership of the game and
they're doing a really good job and and
really battling against the driver head
team so that's all for me so now I'd
like to invite not sure Mona Mona mr.
money Oreo back on the stage to do his
conclusions mr. Ponte Kowski all right
so to conclude I'm gonna take a couple
of smiles so first of all remind that
and this is a quote from Erica in fact
which is like if a player has downloaded
the game and he's a new player it
doesn't know or he or she doesn't know
that the game was published five years
ago I have five years ago so this is
something like really important to
remember to keep it fresh and and have
that in mind and so just to conclude so
we've seen that all games still receive
a big number of the downloads and
nowadays so this is incredibly
interesting for you to think about like
how do you explore and to test also that
they have engaged communities and then
they can be very profitable so what you
can do and I think some of the insights
that we've learned so first of all take
decisions based on metrics and be ready
to let the the first success your baby
go well that was the case of 30 bid as
well consider the community we've seen
that the community still is going to be
always it's going to be a problem or
it's going to be like it's going to
react in some way so how do you plan
before I'm publishing if you take that
route and if you decide to revamp the
game
I think Eric mentioned some managerial
lessons he's a he's insights on his
experience with exciting the team
creating and motivating the developers
in order to really work together to grow
the game again and with these thank you
very much